there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
hi everyone its charlie you guys have
all probably heard the news that
taskmaster seems like he's going to be
the villain or one of the villains of
Black Widow
they've just cast another person Ray
Winstone is probably gonna be a Russian
general who will be one of the other
villains of the movie but we also saw
that we're probably gonna get a version
of Jelena Bulova the second Black Widow
who are Black Widow NAT will be training
during the movie luckily there's a lot
of deleted scenes in moments that
they've had in previous Marvel films
that have addressed what's going on in
this movie so we'll play some of those
deleted scenes later in this video - if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we're gonna get spider-man far from home
next week there's a new round of that
imax ticket giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
an Avengers or spider-man comment on the
video the whole big thing with
taskmaster is that he was almost part of
a live-action series if you remember
there was an agent of shield spin-off
called most-wanted with hunter and
Adrianne Palicki 'he's Mockingbird
character at the network wound up
passing after they saw the pilot
apparently they just didn't want to go
in whatever direction the show was going
but taskmaster was supposed to be a big
character on that TV show if you're not
really familiar with the character I'll
do a quick rundown about how his powers
work but you may remember him more
recently from the spider-man ps4 game
these are a couple of the scenes with
some of the dialogue that he appeared in
you you were on my neighbor's porch for
Halloween
if you know my moves you know I'm gonna
wreck you surprise me if you can
who's out taskmaster why are you
stalking me an organization hired me to
rather be jonah Jameson's foot masseur
than work for anyone who'd hire you your
loss
they pay sex figures guess some people
just deserve to be four six figures yeah
stealing all spider-man's best moves so
as you saw during that clip basically
his powers are the ability to copy other
people's abilities after seeing them
once so if he's in a fight with someone
he'll learn their abilities instantly
and learn to anticipate them so that's
why it's so hard to fight him and that's
why he's able to be an Avengers villain
because that's where he started in the
comics he was a big villain for the
Avengers in the 80s he was a really big
character during the Avengers
initiatives storyline during the
mid-2000s then during Marvel's Civil War
comic book Civil War the US government
hired him to lead a team of Thunderbolts
to go round up people that refused to
sign the superhero Registration Act so
he's a mercenary he's mostly in
antagonist for the heroes so you think
of him as a villain but because his a
mercenary his allegiance just sways to
whoever is paying in the most so he'll
fight with the Avengers if the Avengers
were to pay him enough money just to be
clear though he's not enhanced he
doesn't have special powers you could
think of his ability as a special power
but he's not special in the way that
Scarlet Witch is special like she's a
mutant in the comics but she's also
called enhanced in the MCU although
there have been some source books that
have called her a mutant inside the MCU
they're kind of tricky about the way
they referenced mutants before the big
Fox deal went down he's appeared in a
couple different animated series and for
the most part they try to stay accurate
to the skull looking mask in his comic
book costume this is the version that it
looks like the movies going to go with
without any special effects editor'
color correction definitely looks like a
version of the skull mask that he's
wearing in a cloak obviously this scene
is him riding in a tank he seems like
he's probably been hired by whoever the
main villain of the movies going to be
so he'll be sort of the mid bad even
though if you're a big comic book fan
you'll recognize that Jelena Bulova was
of the bigger black widow villains in
the comics when she graduated from the
Red Room they set her to the task of
tracking down Natasha Romanoff killing
her then taking her mantle and becoming
the new Black Widow so blonde Black
Widow make makes me wonder if that's why
they made Natasha blonde during infinity
war just to get us used to the idea of a
blonde Black Widow but as you can see
the character in this movie is way
younger and even though there might be
some Easter eggs for their fights during
the comics eventually in the comics they
wound up working together and becoming
friends right now all we know about the
timeline of the movie is that
Sebastian's Stan said that it's supposed
to take place between Captain America
Civil War in the events of infinity war
there's this whole two-year period of
history that we don't know about when
Captain America was running around the
world with the secret Avengers we knew a
little bit about them taking down arms
dealers but Black Widow also spent a lot
of time in Eastern Europe it seems like
that's what this series will cover
including very familiar place Budapest
so guess where the Black Widow set
designer was just spotted taking
pictures and where the movie was spotted
filming in Budapest so even if they
don't answer every single Budapest
reference that's been made it sounds
like they'll explain at least a little
bit of what happened in Budapest
quote-unquote
there have been five different
references in five different big Marvel
movies to Budapest these are all those
scenes some of them are from deleted
scenes there was even a Budapest
reference during spider-man homecoming
if you can believe it what are you doing
she's disabling security protocols and
dumping all the secrets onto the
Internet including hydras and shields
if you do this none of your past is
gonna remain hidden
now Budapest another Saka not to
children's war
be sure you're ready for the world to
see you as you really are are you
we'll look out the window it doesn't
matter what our enemies think about us
anymore that's why they're going down a
pretty high opinion of Rogers chances
clearly you haven't been paying
attention when I came out of the ice
I thought everyone I had known was gone
I found out she was alive
I was just lucky to have her
she had you back too after everything
happened with shield during my little
hiatus I went back to Russia and tried
to find my parents
two little gravestones by a chain-link
fence I pulled some weeds and left some
flowers
we have what we have when we have it
[Music]
rising shine Midtown Science and
Technology I'm Betty Brant we don't know
who taskmaster is working for during
this movie he's worked for Norman Osborn
shield agency X the shadow initiative
aim the Thunderbolts in the frightful
four so they could be using any of those
organizations but it sounds like it's
going to be people in the vestiges of
the Red Room trying to come for her her
past coming to bite her in the ass all
the red that she has in her ledger like
when Alexander Pierce during that Winter
Soldier deleted scene is referencing all
these terrible things that she did do
you want the world finding out about
that but as most of you have probably
seen the Logan movie remember what Logan
did with x-23 he found a younger version
of himself and tried to rescue her from
this terrible life that she had been
born into they're trying to turn you
into a weapon
don't be the thing that they created you
to be pretty safe to say that's gonna be
some of the themes of the movie where
you have our Black Widow trying to teach
the young black widow Jelena Bulova that
she does not have to be this crazy
mercenary killer that they trained her
to be the only other times that she's
referenced her past in a really big way
we're doing that Avengers age of Ultron
scene with the Hulk where she's
explaining why she can't have children
anymore their quote unquote graduation
ceremony
[Music]
I had this dream the kind of seems
normal at the time but when you wake
what did you trim but I was an Avenger
that I was anything more than the
assassin they made me I can't ever I
can't have this kids through the math I
physically can't neither can I
[Music]
in the Red Room where I was trained
where I was raised
they have a graduation ceremony they
sterilize you
it's efficient one less thing to worry
about the one thing that might matter
more than a mission makes everything
easier even killing this is some pretty
hardcore flashback so just expect them
to address that during the course of the
Black Widow movie everything that you
ever wanted to know about the things
that she talks about in references when
she's talking to Hawkeye and the other
Avengers well let me know in the
comments what do you think about
taskmaster obviously this is just a
really early look at what he's probably
going to be we don't know who's playing
him but because he's such a big comic
book character that fans have wanted for
such a long time it's probably gonna be
somebody that you've heard of before
there's a whole bunch of other Marvel
videos that I'm working on this week
there's at Avengers endgame deleted
scenes in that new post-credit scene
I'll do a video for that later this week
there's more spider-man far from home
stuff happening there's also some big
non Marvel stuff that's happening so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see the videos when I
post them no worries congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Ralph
Christian Burton please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details while you wait for
everything click here for that brand new
spider-man bar from hone trailer with a
really cool new Iron Man scene and click
here for that new Thor guardians of the
galaxy three teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]